[Music]
what's going on everybody
Yass this is the gayest [ __ ] podcast
in the universe because it's Pride Month
so let's get the gay out together yeah
happy pride everybody I'm Christie in
the closet but I'm [ __ ] out of the
closet today I just got I went on the
website and I just bought a shirt I'm
gonna post a picture of it it's a shirt
that says finish him and it's two guys
blowing each other it's just what it is
yeah I'm listened today it's gonna be
good episode it's Gay Pride it's the
it's June you really feel it here in the
West Village you feel it right in your
ass in the West Village
um and so we're gonna talk about
Michelangelo who make no mistake was a
gay [ __ ] kid that loved to paint and
listen Michelangelo was a kid beautiful
painter but make no mistake that kid
behind closed doors was doing a little
bit of spinning the wheel he spun the
wheel a few times yes what is in between
his Medici Commission sculptures that
kid took a few eggplants cuts the truth
of the situation is I know it's not
popular opinion but if you're a man and
it's nothing wrong with this but if
you're Manning you're a hairdresser or
you're an artist or you're a nurse
you're just a gay guy you just you just
got a little bit of gay in you and
that's okay I was a pediatric physical
therapist and they said the the women
it's mostly a female job oriented job
and the women when they first when I
first got to it like you have to be
gained it was like I'm not gay
but now 10 years later guess what they
were right you just couldn't see it at
the time because you had pushed it down
yeah I pushed it down but now make no
mistake my load it up because your buys
are in I'm bi bi Zarina and my father's
diabetes is getting uncontrollable so
he's getting close and the gay is coming
out its creeped out every tell every
every every time my dad sugar goes up I
get a little bit closer to sucking a
[ __ ] yeah it's what it is just gonna
come up but I've noticed that like the
tries used to be strong because you were
pushing it down yeah but now that you're
pulling it out yeah they let the gay up
your buys are starting to show a little
bit does make notice I put in tended pie
intended one day make no mistake I'm
gonna pull one right into my mouth yeah
cuz we need an animator please whoever
you are out there we know we got a few
founders I need you to make the cartoon
where Chris's uvula is getting hit by a
dick and it looks like a speed bag it's
what it is especially since you throw
hands we need it it's raining out
beautiful day in deutschland should we
just do this whole podcast and
stereotypical gay voice in honor of the
LGBTQ community well the thing is yes I
want to say yes but it's 2019 and there
are a lot of straight men straight white
men that have wives and children that
talk like this very proudly Father's Day
on somebody happy Father's Day to all
the fathers out there shoutouts mattel
water shouts it's our water department
happy Father's Day to anybody who's got
a dick oh it's just everyone you know
whether you have it before what have you
got a post-op happy Father's Day
yeah so one of the one of the dads on
the thread that we have that we
communicate with it's like oh you know
doughnuts
I know it's doughnuts with dad but don't
you think it's a little we shouldn't be
giving our kids we shouldn't be
promoting doughnuts and sugar could we
make it something else
could we make it like a fruit and I say
that this is the moment I know and I'm
certain of that crystal clear Chrissy
turns into steel pipe Chrissy Erica here
comes yeah and I said look guy
I said thing is if your freak of a kid
right you because you're a [ __ ] freak
make no mistake you're a [ __ ] freak
if you're riding that [ __ ] on a public
forum you know to the school you're a
[ __ ] freakazoid okay you're in Bay
Ridge Brooklyn
okay he's making you not feel comfy one
feet yeah he's making me not feel comfy
bumpy okay this isn't Portland OR gonna
make that a t-shirt Mike write it down
comfy mom he's gotta be sharp
comfy-womfy
the thing is your kid I know that sugar
is bad I know it's the enemy I listen I
know that sugar and white men are the
enemy I know those are the biggest
problems that we have in the United
States are sugar and straight white man
I am where you don't think Michelangelo
painted his [ __ ] a little bit yeah I
mean it was different being gay back
then though yeah he had one its disputed
whether it was a lover or not nobody
knows but his name was Tommaso Cavallari
I'm 33 he wrote a Michelangelo
saying I flee from evil deeds and wish
to flee them for I cannot make love with
anyone but you didn't want to bang out a
little babies a gay kid he's a gay kid
he was he said he wants to make love
with any
but this kid Thomas exactly so this is
one of the sonnets that his nephew when
he published his son he changed he made
her all these poems of subject female
but it's not that line right there cuz
it's not a fact nobody knows for sure if
he was gay but he liked to sculpt
he liked to sculpt men and they looked
hot they looked hot he had no wife he
had no kids and he always hung out with
this kid for decades this kid was
actually at his funeral yeah he was by
his side the whole time and this was the
ideal of so he and he also went with his
full first name which according to my
father Tony dak Fred Flintstone if you
go at your full first name Michelangelo
Steven you know Jonathan it means you're
a gay kid
if you would've went as Mike it's a
different thing but it's a pretty a
full-proof that's what he thinks like
yeah if like any guy and like if you
want reduce yourself as Steven he'd like
you was guys sucks [ __ ] yeah I'm trying
to think Matteo it's all get would you
shorten a bit Matt if it's four letters
or under like if it's John or Joe or
something like that then it's no problem
but if you're over a few letters like
you Yanis he's like yeah yes cultural he
doesn't know what to make of it but you
know yeah like if Mike mosh was Michael
mosh he'd be like yeah what's an easy
gay guy who said what the guy most
unwise gay kid his name's Michael yeah
so if your father probably everyone has
one Greek friend they called the Greek
yeah oh yeah yeah cuz I had a friend
Demetrius the Greek the Greek yeah yeah
he we just call him D the Greek the
Greek I posted a picture of myself in
front of a thing a thing I saw on Friday
down in the West Village it said mom mom
I'm gay and I talked to posted a picture
of me in front of it and I got all these
messages from gay people being like
thank you for being an ally I think you
for being an ally it's like the fact
that people want to hurt gay people it's
just beyond my comprehension why you
would want theirs what what do gay
people do if they control the population
yeah [ __ ] fantastic
yeah it's aggressive great yeah yeah for
your service absolutely thank you
because you know some of these kids like
I'd rather I'd rather have [ __ ] gay
guys running around than some of these
that some of these children that you
know are just a little annoying and not
at the beach a lot yeah I just you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah beach goers
yeah the beach goers yeah
yeah you know these kids we also can't
act like listen if you go to a
neighborhood and you see a lesbian
couple walking around and it's a
dangerous neighborhood buy a house in
their neighborhood their neighborhoods
about to get [ __ ] cute lesbians are
like the Marines of gentrification yeah
they're in first
yeah off lesbians like Park Slope we
started seeing lesbians walk around yeah
and that's when you're supposed to buy a
house cuz that neighborhood's gonna flip
gay people make [ __ ] look nice our gay
peers I mean Matteo Lane the creativity
the vision that the talent that that kid
has off the charts Tim Dylan a totally
different kind of gay yeah he's like a
straight kick a straight gay guy but
still his mind the way it works like to
lose gay people is to lose like the most
creative people we have so Tim Dylan's
the kind of guy who wants to [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of Matteo 100% right but he
never can
he never yeah what happens if Tim Dylan
yeah if Rogen if one day decides to step
away from Tim Dylan's career Tim Dylan's
gonna be like this kid making
Michelangelo be born appraised he was
and then you kid was an artist the
mother of the mother he had the father
situation the mother the mother died
early she which I think he drank herself
to death yeah and and then he would go
on to create the biggest thing is the
Sistine Chapel yeah he was raised by a
wet for let's be let's be honest a lot
of my friends think it's a 16th chapel
there's 15 other ones the 16 yeah paddy
flyballs Deebo were my boys like that
they think that's 15 are the ones and he
did the 16 [ __ ] 80 Chris you going [ __ ]
knee going to 60 well meet me Andy will
be over at the 12 and 13 we're gonna go
we're gonna go in order we want to see
him in order I would see Madonna so we
could start at one these guys starting
at 16 he thought painting was gay
Michelangelo yeah he really thought it
was gay and he hated when people
referred to him as a painter that's why
he reluctantly painted the Sistine
Chapel right it was he I think he did
sculptures for like 12 popes or whatever
the hell it was a lot of popes but he
one of the Pope's asked him to to carve
his mausoleum his - yeah but
was most famous work to st. Peter's
Basilica yeah well he designed that I
think he was an architect which is crazy
yeah you think he actually built it he
was a Renaissance man Oh didn't he also
have an original version of a plane in
like the 1600 no that wasn't that was
Leonardo da Vinci at the same time she
was a little older they actually didn't
like each other they they were rivals
they were repetitive with each other
yeah yeah but he did do it the Pieta
which is gorgeous I've seen in person
I've been to Florence
obviously the David and everyone says
well if David's got really big hands and
the reason was because the David was
initially supposed to be like high up
over the city and he wanted the they
wanted the Medici family and all the
politicians at that time the powerful
people wanted a bunch of big biblical
characters all around the city but they
realized how hard it was to lift David
up
so they just canceled all the rest of
them and just do the David and because
it was so beautiful and the detail was
so great they decided to have it lower
so people could see all the deep where
is it right now
so it's hearts they're just in Florence
just in Florence in the museum
so it's behind you know you can't even
see it it's so the mob of people that go
to see it but it's really big and there
it is and he's got a tiny piece but you
know what
Mediterranean kids were growing big head
- he does have a big head but they made
him Michelangelo made those proportions
the big head in the big hands because
this sculpture was initially meant to be
up high you're supposed to be looking
right up at it yeah but yeah but his
piece still stayed small piece says
warning and he gave him pubes so the kid
had fumes yeah I mean they couldn't they
couldn't manscape back then everybody
had gnomes yeah and he had big kami who
knows me big hands you know yeah but
maybe that could be maybe one in [ __ ]
a big cans maybe that's his fantasy yeah
and maybe he was a grower you know maybe
when you first put the piece in the
mouth it felt like you were doing a
little bit of pig in a blanket but then
it grew up now let me ask you a question
as you're looking at the statue aren't
absolutely
what book scroll down yeah we got
there's only one thing with Yanni defeat
let's go to the beat what do you think a
look become you zoom in on the feed
because that's the only thing that
that's Yanni's only thing is you got
haven't he can't have jack the feet he's
not going to go down there yeah
gonna crack you open and clean you out
what do you think of the feed did do a
nice job on the feet let's see nice kids
got nice he's gonna walk he's got long
toes doll so if I could press a button
and make David come to life you put that
foot right in your mouth I put it right
in my mouth yeah cuz would you back him
out would you crack open to clean out
David yeah I just spin the wheel with
David he was obviously a gifted talented
guy to be able to do this stuff like my
friend Jesse's couture Oh can do sculpt
and paint you're just born I could not
paint you a smurf I can't draw you a
smurf everything I draw looks like a
stick figure this he carved that out of
marble with the chisel he took a block
of marble and made that look like that
like how do you even begin to comprehend
how to do that is unbelievable but
anyway the Medici family was they were
bankers and they were like the most
powerful family this was during the
Renaissance influence they controlled
Florence and they commissioned him early
on right left Medici family like he
started working for the Medicis like 17
then he started working I became famous
the piata it was like his first big
sculpture and it made him absolutely
famous the Piazza there it is that is
and I think it did trade the piata I
think it means pity right in English
does it yeah and it's the Virgin Mary
who yours you shouldn't be making your
[ __ ] cross right now yeah it's a
Virgin Mary and there's a dead Jesus
yeah it's brutal but it's an absolute
beautiful beautiful sculpture and from
there he got famous then he was asked to
create the tomb for the for the for the
Pope he went to Rome and and painted the
Sistine Chapel reluctantly because he
didn't want to be a painter and Plus
nobody wanted to do that job cuz you
have to lay on your back and do it Yeah
right wild the way he painted that is
wild on his back on this huge
scaffolding and it's not like it's not
icky at Helpers he painted every detail
I painted that [ __ ] himself
yeah you can't if you're a painter you
can't own a paint company you have to do
it you're the one that has the art to do
it it's crazy dude the Pieta he he did
the Pieta that sculpture which is I
think a six feet by six feet block of
marble he did that in a year which is
crazy and I think he did that in his
early 20s have you ever seen this stuff
we've been I've seen it I've seen the
piata I haven't
David but I have seen the Pieta in
Florence it's all in Florence yeah and
go to his Moses okay so some of his work
is in Florence some is in Rome yeah have
you seen a vanity huh you've been there
you've been cause you're not gonna ever
date a girl who's been seeing the yeah
yeah yeah who's who's seen any of
Michelangelo's work in person that's
just not your demo not what it is yeah
you ever been down to Jersey Shore
Museum and you see like how the Greeks
did it you know in their statues and how
beautiful they are and then it's and
then you walk the Italian room you just
like you forget about the degree key
Greeks even existed that doesn't happen
no it does because the the the detail
that the Italians have is
un-fuckin'-believable and not only can
they do it on a big scale but they could
do it some of these statues are
microscopic and these kids have [ __ ]
cut them up yeah you know not only can
they do a good sculpture they can also
throw it out some good concrete in your
backyard Yeah right down yeah you need a
pool built and you need you need some
you need some marble or you need some
masonry done yeah yeah call Sally
goossens cause those company I guarantee
you there's not a place in the world
where the water doesn't move as [ __ ] it
doesn't flow as smooth as it doesn't
Smith down it's got good water good boy
shouts Whittell water department does
anyone need another water I'd like to
have another water but I also got a
paper could be an STD wild about Italian
kids especially back then they do have
long wild names because Michelangelo's
full name is Michael Angelo di Lodovico
Buonarroti Simoni Wow Wow but Greeks
have long wild name still yeah but we
know you know the difference between
Greeks is our our names are long these
guys have a lot of last name I
understand we mean like what's your
guy's name again who made the suit
giovanni brush eonnie
Giovanni Villani this guy's Michael
Enzo's is Michael Angelo di Lodovico
bueno ratty signor Denis Simoni yeah
that's his full [ __ ] name it's a full
[ __ ] man it was born in 1475 I was
born in 1975 two kids
Wow trio G is a PHA yeah
we're [ __ ] cute kids cuz you acuteness
500 years yeah look buzz so Michelangelo
enclosing in nicosia he was a kid who
loved to paint and spin the wheel he
liked to spin the wheel he was a gay kid
he was a gay kid today he'd be the most
featured guests on Ellen yeah I mean
look you gotta just allow gay people to
be gay people they're just everyone's
doing their own thing way outweigh the
cons it's pro and it just like mind your
own [ __ ] my own [ __ ] business let
these people have fun let these people
live their [ __ ] life and do the right
thing you know let them whatever they be
happy they're great parents a great
artist and even if they're not at any of
that they're just great people let them
do what they want to do behind closed
doors they're not getting into heaven
so either way either way [ __ ] believe
yeah seriously shout out all my all my
gay friends you know only once I could
take [ __ ] top my head Matteo Lane Tim
Dylan yeah Mike mush think about
Michelangelo is his lover was so much
younger than him this guy was this
nobleman yeah and that's all he had
there's there's no everything else is
sort of a mystery there's no kind of
recorded history on who exactly he was
banging out but he definitely based on
his writings which is all we know his
letters to this kid he was obsessed with
this young kid this kid must have been a
piece the kid must have been a [ __ ]
piece and a nice little piece and and
yeah man so support the gays happy pride
that was Michelangelo thank you guys for
watching don't forget to subscribe also
turn on alerts or to come he'll frown
absolutely and go to patreon.com/scishow
a rich boys to join the matriarchy with
things here really why
[Music]